the Harry Potter books may be meant for
kids but certain parts belong in the
Restricted Section for example there's
the ingor Geo spell which seems like a
poor choice of name on Rowling's part
and is probably the only explanation for
how Hagrid's father made Whoopi with a
giantess I shouldn't have said that I
should not have said that then there's
the fact that these are all teenage
students who've had no sex ed coursework
at all some trace the timing of
nymphadora tonk's conception to her
parents teen years rolling herself has
said she didn't mean to encourage teen
pregnancy in the story but thanks to a
dirty Easter egg in the Marauders map
from the Prisoner of Azkaban movie we
know Hogwarts could get pretty steamy
with or without proper education about
safe sex